they're depressed about our show getting
canceled so we thought we'd cover a
subject that will make you even more
depressed the opioid epidemic that's
right it's time for our last night the
show super depressing deep dive take a
look hi hey you good not for long
welcome to another nightly show super
depressing deep dive opioids everyone's
talking about though one of the greatest
public health crises of our time the
opioid epidemic an epidemic of drug
abuse we are saying more people killed
because of opioid overdose than traffic
accidents so how did this happen
it starts with pain people hate pain
mainly because it's painful and opioids
take that pain and turn it into you
opioids are any opium like compound like
morphine invented in 1827
and advertise to children yes that baby
won't cry well until you take away its
sweet sweet morphine in 1888 bear tried
to make a less addictive morphine called
heroin now selling legal heroin may
sound crazy but this is during the time
when you could get cocaine in coca-cola
and doctors thought your skull shape
determined how smart you were phrenology
in the 1970s and 80s most doctors
avoided opioids as long-term pain relief
because of the whole addiction thing but
in 1995 Purdue pharmaceuticals savvy at
the branch of Purdue chicken ordered the
safest OBO duvall and everyone was happy
and pain-free forever the and JK pain is
life it will never go away like YouTube
and Guy Fieri hey turns out oxycontin is
crazy addictive but to make it seem make
a awesome Purdue handed out branded
promotional items like fishing hats and
CDs yes that's the title
it isn't even clever like oxy cotton eye
Joe there were also plush toys which we
couldn't find images of so we assumed
they'd look like this
and to help use everyone's fear of
addiction Purdue created videos with
super trustworthy dudes they don't wear
out they go on working they do not have
serious medical side effects thank you
kindly dr. Doug guy who was totally not
paid to say that I bet he was paid to
say that
a year later opioid prescription
strength I originally those are simply
upper level numbers but without the ads
that make you think of your parents
doing anyway
sales of oxycontin went from 44 million
in 1986 Jacka yacht money to 1.5 billion
in 2002 by 2012 doctors wrote more than
259 million prescriptions for opioids
enough to give a bottle to every adult
in America you don't have to be a
chicken scientist another when
everyone's got opioids opioid overdoses
are going to skyrocket more than 165
thousand people have died of costs
related to painkiller use since 1999
including the man who left a party like
it's 1999 tests show the music icon
Prince died of an opioid overdose that's
right there's greedy drug company
bastards mother who killed mother
or maybe the drug companies didn't know
maybe they were innocent pawns in this
game of chance we call life I'm just
playing of course they knew the LA Times
reported the Purdue marketed oxycontin
as a 12 hour drug when they do it often
only worked for eight leading patients
to experience withdrawal and want higher
more dangerous doses which means we
relied to you by kindly CD hat doctor
tape guy they do not have serious
medical side effects what the dude they
hid the evidence of illegal oxy rings
and in 2007 they lost 635 million dollar
lawsuit and three executives pleaded
guilty and was branding the drug and
downplaying the risk of addiction even
Big Tobacco was like damn you guys are
scumbags that lawsuit was nine years ago
but we're only addressing this crisis
now why for the first time in any first
world country the death rate for white
middle-aged people is on the rise yep
opioids became a national epidemic
because it became a white people problem
ash Daggett now hospitals and doctors
feel super bad about hurting white
people so they're cracking down on over
prescribing and abuse so is it all
better yeah wait no because when addicts
stop getting opioids they turn to the
next best thing that's right our old
friend heroin is back
it's like opioid fast food cheap easy
and it's colorful mascots will haunt
your nightmares for eternity so now
there's a new white people problem then
in Tucket polo club is full of heroin
addicts and if that wasn't fun enough
big pharma still makes billions of our
pain by selling opioids and we still
don't have an effective not addictive
chronic pain medication now we just have
heroin killing more people than ever
depressed good then my job here is done
this has been another nightly show super
depressing deep dive
you